After the fall of
the Soviet Union,
and even China's migration
to a market-based economy--
even though they call
themselves Communists,
their economy is now,
essentially, capitalist--
there's been a general
consensus around the world
that capitalism
is the way to go.
And just to put my bias out
there, right from the get go,
I am in that camp.
I would consider
myself a capitalist.
But what I want to do in this
video is do a little bit more
of a nuanced discussion
of capitalism
versus, say, socialism.
Because I feel like there
has been-- especially here,
in the United States,
and in the West--
a knee jerk reaction
against anything
that even has a whiff of the
government getting involved
or even a whiff of socialism.
So I want to think
more about what are we
trying to achieve with
the capitalist system.
And where we could
fall into the things
we don't want to achieve if some
of the aspects of capitalism
are allowed to go on
without any type of controls
or, maybe, some
type of regulation.
I don't want to
advocate anything.
I just want to give, maybe,
a framework for thinking
about it.
So you ask any capitalist,
including myself, you
say, well, what's
good about capitalism?
And I would say,
well, you know it
aligns everyone's incentives.
So it's good incentives.
If you work harder,
you can earn more,
you can generate a
capital for yourself.
You can use that to improve
your standard of living.
You can reinvest that capital.
So it's a good
incentive structure.
I'm not saying that
everyone is motivated purely
by the desire to earn.
I think there's plenty of people
in the world who are motivated
for the desire for social
good, for elevating mankind.
But the general census
in a lot of parts of--
is that those type of things
are specific to certain domains.
But, in other domains, if
someone's running a trucking
company, it's not clear that
someone would run a trucking
company optimally just
for the good of mankind.
Maybe they would run some
type of nonprofit that way.
But a trucking
company, or a farm,
or something like
that, who knows.
So in general, you have a
good incentive structure.
There's also this notion
in a capitalist economy
that it's a meritocracy.
It is meritocracy.
And I'm going to,
actually, put a box
around this because a
meritocracy, in my mind,
is super duper important.
Because even if you talk
to us-- almost everyone
is a fan of a meritocracy.
Even the communists were
a fan of a meritocracy.
They would give exams
to people and have
the people who were
successful have
more authority within
the communist regime.
So a meritocracy is something
that everyone lays claim to.
And actually a lot of
socialists or communists
would claim that extreme forms
of capitalism, when the wealth
disparity becomes two extreme
or where you have inherited
wealth, actually goes against
the idea of meritocracy.
So let me actually put
meritocracy here as well.
And we'll talk about
that in a second.
And then the other
ideas is that you
have innovation in capitalism.
And these are all related ideas.
That if the incentives
are good, if capital
gets in the hands of people
who are most deserving of it
because they've somehow earned
it, they've somehow innovated,
that can also lead to innovation
because the right people
are handling the capital.
Now, if we go to the
socialist side of things,
they'll say, well, look, there's
a social cohesiveness to this.
So let me write this down.
And I won't speak
to the-- I don't
claim what I'm going to do in
this video is comprehensive
of all of the pros
and cons of either.
I just want to give a little
bit of nuance to the discussion.
So social cohesiveness.
You won't have this
situation where
you have a gazillionaire
sitting behind a walled compound
with armed guards
and their people
right on the other side of
that walled compound starving
to death.
And these people don't
even, necessarily,
view themselves as part
of the same society,
that they somehow have a
responsibility to each other.
And that is happening in
some parts of the world
where you have severe
disparities in wealth.
The rich people don't
even view themselves
as the same species as the
poor people or even vice versa.
You have the other
idea of-- and I'll
put this in quotes-- fairness.
And I'll put it in quotes
because one could say,
well, it's fair if you make
more, if you work harder,
you should get more.
If you innovate more,
And then their
notion of fairness
says, well, yeah, but look
sometimes this wealth gets
so extreme. sometimes
you have this notion
of inherited wealth.
Generation after generation.
Old money.
What's fair about that?
That people are
just randomly born
into a situation where they can
just extract the interest off
of their wealth and
never have to work.
And other people have
to work super hard
and they really
get nothing for it.
So this notion of fairness,
I'll put it over here as well.
Fairness.
Because there's
arguments for either.
And so, like I
said, I'm definitely
biased to the capitalist
side of things.
I think there is an
importance to these things
that we have on the
right hand side.
But the reality,
at least what we've
seen in the economic
experiments of the 20th century,
is that even though communists
and socialists might speak
to these types of
things, to a large degree
there's less social
cohesiveness.
The senior communists
in the Soviet Union
would drive fancier cars.
And they did have a very
different lifestyle then
the workers.
And they would hide
that lifestyle.
And then it would lead
to a lot of hypocrisy.
In general, the extreme
forms of socialism-- not
clear that it was a meritocracy.
It might have been just
the best people climbing up
the party ladder that
get to the top as opposed
to the people who would
innovate and actually
produce in a better way.
But with that said, I
want to give fair warning,
that capitalism, if it goes
unchecked in certain ways,
it could also lead to those
same problems of socialism.
And the main problems
there, when you
think about good incentives.
I think the incentives,
and once again,
I'm giving my opinion
here, the incentives
work out well when you
have a bunch of competitors
who can compete and innovate.
And it makes complete
sense that, let's say,
that this person comes
up with an innovation.
And because they
have that innovation,
they're able to provide a better
good that's cheaper to society.
And so they make more profits.
And it seems
reasonable that person
should get more profits,
and more wealth, and grow.
And it could even
be good for society
because this person's
an innovator.
Maybe there was an
element of luck there.
But it seems like they're
competent at managing
these resources.
So it's good for society to give
them more resources to manage.
The areas where it becomes
less clear that capitalism
is unambiguously
good, is a situation
where this person becomes
out right dominate.
So let's say that this person
becomes so big that none
of these other players can
even compete with them.
So they all disappear.
This person can just
undercut everybody.
And all the other
players disappear.
And this is the
situation of a monopoly.
And the problem here is,
when this guy had competition
he had every incentive
to work harder.
He had every
incentive to innovate.
It was a meritocracy because
the person who innovates well
grows the fastest.
But once you get to
a monopoly stage,
and everyone else
has died down, this
is the only player in the
economy, then all of a sudden,
he has no incentive to innovate.
This corporation or this person
can just keep raising prices.
There's no competition.
There's no one else to say,
hey, I can have a better product
or I can sell it to you cheaper.
And so it actually goes against
the ideas of innovation.
That's why it's
really important.
And that's why it's part
of, especially in the United
States, the economic system that
you try to break up monopolies.
That you don't like
monopolistic practices.
The other risks
that you have when
you start having a lot of
wealth and a lot of influence
in one entity, or one
person, or one corporation--
and this can happen in a
democratic or even a non
democratic regime-- is that,
the control of resources
aren't just control
of those resources.
Aren't just control of land,
and buildings, and railroads.
They can also use it to
influence government.
And in the United
States, this has
been institutionalized
in the form of lobbying.
And when you have
excess resources
and you can influence
government in this way,
you can get the
government-- so let's say
this is the government
over here-- to,
essentially, do things for you.
So it works to your advantage.
And may be allowing
you, eventually,
to become a monopoly.
So you can view this
as crony capitalism,
where lobbying can be a
form of legalized bribery.
And in that way, you kind of
own the elected officials.
I'm not saying that this
is happening everywhere
but it could happen.
And in that situation,
you have the government
acting on behalf of these.
And, once again, it goes against
the idea of a meritocracy
because when you have
this cycle developing,
maybe this person right over
here has the innovation.
But this person
doesn't have the clout,
doesn't have the influence
with the government.
And so this guy gets
the government contract
for the planes.
Or this guy gets the tax
benefits from the government
so that he can be
even more competitive.
He can undercut this
guy even though this guy
has the innovation.
The other element-- and I could
talk about this for hours.
And these are just
things to think
about-- are the idea
of inherited wealth.
And I'm not saying
that inherited wealth
is a bad thing.
But there's this idea
that, let's say, someone
through their competence,
maybe competence
with a little bit of
luck, is able to accrue
a huge amount of wealth.
And maybe they're not
even a monopolist.
But they're able to get
a huge amount of wealth.
But they were able to do
it-- that they're really
good managers.
They're kind of these
really smart dude.
He can he can really manage
a lot of resources well.
The question arises
is, what happens
when this person passes away?
In a very purely
capitalist situation,
you pass this onto
your children.
So you pass this
onto your children.
And the issue here is, one, what
did this person do to earn it?
And also from a society's
point of view, maybe
this person here is a dummy.
Maybe there was
another kid over here
who was born at the exact
same time, who is way smarter
and who-- but this kid is now
in control over 100 gazillion
dollars.
And he can completely
mismanage the resources
so that they're
completely wasted.
And so you have this idea
of-- over time-- inherited
wealth in a
capitalist society can
go against the ideas
of meritocracy.
It can go against the
idea of good incentives
because if this guy
inherits enough money,
he has no incentive to work.
Why should he have to study
hard and go and tackle
math and all that?
He's inherited
enough money that he
gets millions of dollars
just off of the interest.
Why should he educate himself?
He got daddy's or
granddad's money.
And so it also goes against
the idea-- and why should
he try to innovate?
Why should he ever do anything?
He could maybe just hire
some of these people
and give them a minimum
salary, whatever it takes.
And so it goes against these
ideas of fairness and all that.
And I'm not saying that
I'm against inheritance.
I'm just saying this is
something to think about.
And there's some, probably,
threshold of inheritance
that it starts to undermine
some of these ideas
of a meritocracy, and good
incentives, and fairness,
and all that.
And that's why I
think it's funny
when people who call themselves
"old money" are proud of it.
They view themselves
as, somehow,
being part of a better caste
because "old money" means
that you did not earn
the money yourself.
That your granddad or you're
great grandad earned the money.
And you've just happened to be
born in this family and are,
essentially, just living
off of the interest.
And it's funny because
they'll talk about "new money"
as if they're not as
good as old money.
But at least in new
money people-- maybe
it was through
luck, but maybe it
was through competence or
innovation-- this is something
that, at least in my mind,
I'd respect more than old.
Old money, you've done nothing.
What's the difference
between old money,
or a king and a queen, or
the aristocracy of Europe,
that goes against a lot of the
philosophical underpinnings
of what the United
States is even based on.
So I'll leave you there.
I just want to add a
little bit of a nuance
to the conversation.
And I will say--
I'll say it again--
I come to this conversation
with a capitalist bias.
But I'm hoping
that this gives you
a little bit of more nuance.
So that instead of
saying, capitalism
is an unambiguous
good and socialism
is an unambiguous bad,
these are the things
that we should try to promote.
And to do that, we do
have to do some things,
like make sure that
everyone is educated
so that we can
have a meritocracy.
If everyone is educated, then
you have a level playing field.
You have this notion
of equal opportunity.
And that does involve some
type of, on some scale,
redistribution of-- at least
in the form of education.
Maybe you do need some way
for people to get health care.
You don't want people
dying in the streets.
I'm not going to
take a stance here,
but I'm just showing
you that you can't just,
even though I do consider
myself a capitalist,
you can't just say
that everything
has to be purely
capitalist and you
can't have any notion of
government intervention.
You maybe want the
government to invest
in things like
long-term research.
Where they don't have
an immediate profit
motive, but 50, 100
years down the future
it might allow the society
to thrive or whatever else.
So I'll leave you there.